dati quando si parla di dati le reazioni
delle persone sono molto diverse sono
sicuro che in questo momento tra di voi
c'è chi sta sbarrando gli occhi e si
ricorda ancora terrorizzato dall
insegnante di matematica delle scuole
elementari e di quanto sia stato
difficile fare è imparare a fare le
somme senza la calcolatrice e benedice
l'esistenza degli smartphone
c'è chi tra di voi sicuramente associa i
dati alla statistica che non riesce a
capire per quale ragione se il reddito
medio pro capite di 25 mila euro
all'anno nella sua vita non ha mai
guadagnato più di 1.200 euro al mese
c'è anche chi è entusiasta di tutte
queste informazioni ma non riesce e le
utilizza per produrre centinaia di
grafici di tabelle senza capire
esattamente per quale ragione lo sta
facendo
i dati la parola dato dal latino datum
servono a descrivere la realtà
soprattutto in una società complessa
come la nostra sono uno strumento
imprescindibile di analisi e le
informazioni sono un bene preziosissimo
non voglio spaventarvi anche se so di
farlo ma le informazioni scrutano la
nostra vita
pensate alla quantità di informazioni
che in questi minuti sta venendo
comunicata dai nostri smartphone sulla
nostra posizione
o pensate semplicemente alla quantità di
informazioni sulle nostre abitudini di
consumo che viene veicolata attraverso
le carte di credito attraverso le carte
di fedeltà dei supermercati
quando facciamo gli acquisti via
internet pensate ancora l'enorme
quantità di informazione che contenuta
nei dati amministrativi che tracciano la
nostra vita dalla nascita fino alla
morte
la quantità di informazioni contenute
nelle cartelle cliniche nei passaporti
biometrici ogni dimensione umana e ogni
comportamento dell'uomo è fonte di
informazione ma le informazioni sono
importanti e non in quanto tale ma sono
importanti perché ci offrono la
possibilità di essere analizzate e ciò
per una possibilità di comprendere i
fenomeni e soprattutto sono uno
strumento fondamentale di supporto per
le decisioni
politiche quindi per le politiche di
intervento che hanno l'obiettivo di
migliorare la qualità del benessere e
della vita dei cittadini
e ovvio che è fondamentale quando
parliamo di dati capire che dati stiamo
usando e soprattutto sapere la
metodologia e gli strumenti che noi
stiamo usando per interpretare quei dati
ma veniamo finalmente al tema del mio
intervento
la criminalità quando noi parliamo di
criminalità rappresenta una delle
principali preoccupazioni per
l'individuo essere sentirsi insicuri
indipendentemente dall esserlo influenza
in modo significativo il nostro
benessere e vincola le nostre scelte
pensate a quante persone nella loro vita
decidono di non andare in vacanza in
determinati luoghi di non uscire la sera
di non frequentare determinate zone
della città solo ed esclusivamente
perché hanno paura di essere vittima di
un reato
e ovvio che nel momento in cui noi
parliamo di dati
ne parliamo molto spesso in modo vago in
modo poco preciso non ci preoccupiamo di
capire veramente che cosa sta dietro
quel numero che rappresenta il livello
di crimine quando ci sono le famose
graduatorie sulla criminalità
all'interno di un paese normalmente la
nostra principale preoccupazione è
quella di vedere se la nostra città
nella nostra città a livello di
camminata è più alto o più basso che in
un'altra città e ci sentiamo tranquilli
se è più basse ci sentiamo al pericolo
se è più alto ma parliamo di come si
misura il crimine quali sono le fonti
attraverso cui noi siamo in grado di
misurare il crimine innanzitutto abbiamo
le indagini di vittimizzazione oppure le
statistiche ufficiali
le indagini di vittimizzazione sono
delle indagini campionarie che vengono
condotte su un campione rappresentativo
della popolazione che ci consentono di
sapere la percentuale di popolazione che
sono state che è stata vittima di un
crimine
le statistiche ufficiali misurano invece
i reati effettivamente denunciati quanti
di voi deciderebbero di denunciare il
furto di uno dei sette nani che hanno in
giardino
piuttosto che la bicicletta ruggini ta
con la quale ogni mattina vanno in
stazione attende
il treno probabilmente pochissimi questa
è la distribuzione dei furti totali
nelle province italiane e una media per
il periodo che va dal 2004 al 2010 come
notate c'è una forte eterogeneità nella
distribuzione del crimine ma questo non
necessariamente riflette che quelle zone
dove è più scura e quindi dove c'è più
crimine siano effettivamente le zone più
pericolose
quanti di voi invece denunciano il furto
dell'automobile
probabilmente tutti o perché avete
un'assicurazione contro il furto
oppure perché avete paura che con la
vostra automobile possa venire commessi
altri reati
questa è la distribuzione dei furti di
automobili nello stesso periodo a
livello provinciale
notate che l'informazione è
completamente diversa ma non è che
stiamo parlando di reati diversi
chi stiamo parlando sempre di furti la
differenza la fa che i fumi per i furti
d'auto il tasso di denuncia è molto
vicino al cento per cento per i furti
complessivi è molto lontana dal 100 per
cento ed è molto eterogeneo nelle
diverse province italiane
se noi volessimo avere un'informazione
ancora più puntuale ancora più precisa
invece che utilizzare il dato a livello
provinciale
proviamo a utilizzare il dato a livello
comunale questa è la stessa informazione
sui furti d'auto livello comunale che
cosa nottata in questa cartina notate le
grandi città e notate le catene montuose
questo è in proporzione alla popolazione
il dato che non è un dato assoluto sta
dicendo il numero di reati per centinaia
di migliaia di abitanti
questo che cosa significa ci sta dando
un'intuizione che probabilmente là dove
il tasso di urbanizzazione più elevato
c'è maggior densità di popolazione o c'è
maggiore ricchezza potrebbe concentrarsi
il crimine ma invece di concentrarsi
solo ed esclusivamente sulla dinamica
spaziale
proviamo a capire anche come la dinamica
temporale può aiutarci a capire al
crimine questa è l'evoluzione dei furti
d'arte in italia dal 2004 al 2010 quindi
è sempre in rapporto alla popolazione e
come notate un decremento della
criminalità ma se noi invece che
utilizzare il dato a livello annuale lo
utilizzassimo a livello
esile l'informazione che noi abbiamo è
completamente diversa notiamo come i
reati frutti nel tempo ci siano mesi in
cui c è una maggior concentrazione dei
reati e mesi in cui c'è una minor
concentrazione dei reati che capite che
questa informazione è preziosissima
quando poi noi dobbiamo decidere come
allocare le forze di polizia
e ovvio che siamo i dati sono questa
ricchezza di informazioni è estremamente
importante ma è altrettanto vero che
dobbiamo essere in grado di utilizzarla
nel modo giusto e corretto e non basta
raccogliere dati ma dobbiamo anche avere
gli strumenti e le metodologie per
analizzarle
se vogliamo capire l'importanza dei big
data nell'ambito dell'analisi del
crimine dobbiamo purtroppo cambiare
città e spostarsi a barcellona ma avendo
orio molto vicino non è oggettivamente
un problema e con pochi euro possiamo
farlo i mossos d'esquadra che sono la
polizia catalana hanno messo a
disposizione un sistema di raccolta dei
dati a livello georeferenziato che cosa
vuol dire a livello di un referenziato
che per ogni singolo reato che viene
commesso viene registrato il luogo la
data l'ora il tipo di evento e laddove
possibile ovviamente chi l'ha commesso e
la vittima del reato
capite che questa ricchezza di
informazione ci consente per esempio di
sapere in quali mesi dell'anno in quali
giorni della settimana in quale ore del
giorno si concentra maggiormente
l'attività criminale ma non solo ci
consente anche di sapere come il crimine
si distribuisce all'interno di una città
come si distribuisce e come evolve
all'interno di una città e di
conseguenza ci consente di capire quelli
che nel linguaggio di economia del team
e si chiamano gli hot spot ovvero quelle
zone in rosso sono quelle dove c'è la
maggiore intensità criminale per quell
evento questa ricchezza di informazioni
vediamo
nell'esempio di della città di chicago
ci consente anche di associare
all'evento criminale una quantità
pressoché infinita di informazioni ci
consente di sapere se in corrispondenza
o nei luoghi limitrofi al luogo in cui è
stato commesso il reato c'erano dei bar
dei ristoranti dei locali notturni delle
scuole delle stazioni di polizia delle
telecamere l'illuminazione notturna una
quantità enorme di informazioni ci
consente consente di sapere se in quelle
zone è stata quali sono le condizioni
socio demografiche le caratteristiche
socio demografiche di quell'area sia una
zona ricca povera ad alta concentrazione
di popolazione immigrata ad alta
concentrazione di popolazione giovane ci
consente di sapere se quel reato è stato
commesso in particolar modo in
corrispondenza di un evento una partita
di calcio
un concerto piuttosto di sapere se è
stato commesso quando pioveva o quando
c'era il sole
capite che tutte queste informazioni per
quanto si possano sembrare eccessive
sono estremamente importanti perché se
da un lato è vero che queste
informazioni ci descrivono il fenomeno
dall'altro lato ci aiutano a capire le
determinanti e le cause di quel fenomeno
e non solo perché pensate alle decisioni
delle ford della forza di polizia
ovviamente parte dalla descrizione della
comprensione della condizione di
sicurezza di un territorio
ma questa analisi deve essere utilizzata
per risolvere le condizioni di sicurezza
di un territorio
quindi come la polizia viene allocata
dipende anche dalle informazioni che noi
siamo in grado di ottenere nell'esempio
della città di los angeles per esempio
come come vi stavo dicendo viene
allocata la polizia sulla base delle
informazioni ottenute dai dati
georeferenziati e di conseguenza sia un
utilizzo efficiente delle forze di
polizia perché partiamo da un
presupposto le risorse non sono infinite
e devono essere utilizzate nel modo più
efficiente possibile
tutte queste cose possiamo farle
attraverso l'utilizzo delle info dei
dati ma è importante ricordarsi che dati
da soli sono soltanto dati e non serve
un computer per utilizzarli c'è bisogno
di qualcuno che li sappia interpretare
ed analizzare e permettetemi di
concludere con una frase di elio
dove è finita
la conoscenza che abbiamo perso
nell'informazione grazie